[Music]
from NASA's Kennedy Space Center in
Florida you're watching live coverage of
the Parker Solar Probe mission to unlock
mysteries of the sun's atmosphere good
morning I'm Murray Lewis thanks for
waking up super early with us we have
team coverage of today's launch from a
viewing area near the iconic Vehicle
Assembly Building and from our reporters
and commentators at the mission director
Center but first
Parker Solar Probe is targeted to launch
at 353 this morning Eastern Time from
launch complex 37 at Cape Canaveral Air
Force Station the launch window is 65
minutes long Parker will take off on a
United Launch Alliance Delta four heavy
rocket speeding up to four hundred
thirty thousand miles per hour in orbit
that's fast enough to get from
Philadelphia to Washington DC in just
one second it will travel seven times
closer to the Sun than any spacecraft
before her will help us understand how
the Sun affects weather in space coming
up we'll find out how that space weather
can impact our satellites and how Parker
will manage to get so close to our star
without burning up but first we are now
about 51 minutes from launch let's check
in with NASA's Josh Finch and Nick
Waltman in Kennedy's mission director
Center for an update on the count hi
guys good morning Murray I'm Joshua
Finch and I'm joined today by Mick
Walton good morning Josh I'm happy to be
here today representing NASA's launch
services program thank you glad to have
you with us we started out this morning
with a 65 minute window but now we're
sitting at about 45 minutes of our
window and MIT can yet can you tell us a
bit more about that yes Josh United
Launch Alliance and the NASA launch team
has got on station about six hours ago
teams have been working diligently
through some minor issues that occurred
with some ground support equipment prior
to MST roll earlier this evening and
they got through that and in this
Tirol occurred and then the team started
working through the launch procedure
they were doing that they noticed some
sensor data that they didn't really like
so they started looking at that
performed a little troubleshooting on
the vehicle they wanted to make sure all
of that was working prior to going into
the cryogenic load before this early
this morning so once they got that all
done they were ready to proceed forward
so that delayed cryo load just a little
bit with that the cryo poll was taken to
enter into the loading procedure and
NASA's launch manager Omar Baez and you
OAS launch director loom and jury
coordinated a new t0 to help make up and
get things processing back on a nominal
timeline for 353 a.m. this morning and
so we do still have 45 minutes remaining
and our window should the launch teams
need more time you're looking at a live
shot of the delta 4 heavy rocket with
the additional third stage at Space
Launch Complex 37 the weather for today
has actually been improving we started
out late yesterday with some storms in
the area but those are since cleared out
and our weather actually improved
throughout the count our winds are at 5
knots out of the West temperature right
now is about 78 79 degrees the concerns
that we were looking at earlier were
cumulus clouds detached anvil clouds
with a probability of violation of 10
percent that's actually been reduced to
now 5 percent so that means we have 95
percent chance of favorable weather for
launch again you're looking at a live
view of the delta 4 heavy rocket and
behind is the mobile service tower that
mick was talking about that the abroad
back earlier can you tell us a little
bit about the MST role yes MST role went
very smoothly as I said earlier they had
a few issues with some ground support
equipment that got started but once they
got that fixed and moved the MST was
jacked up and began rolling back as it
moved back behind the Delta 4 vehicle
and exposing it to the Sun it was a
beautiful view the MST continued to roll
about 400 feet to the north of the pad
where it got into its parked position
for launch this evening and once that
was accomplished the Delta 4 vehicle was
there in sight for everybody as we can
see here to this evening and back to a
live shot of the delta 4 heavy rocket
mechanic and
new to monitor the countdown from the
mission director center so with the
weather favorable and us looking at the
new t0 at 353 we'll go back to Murray
alright thanks guys
Parker Solar Probe is named after dr.
Eugene Parker a physicist who figured
out sixty years ago that our star
actually has its own wind and storms and
they can spread far into space this
space weather can disrupt communication
signals from our satellites and even
caused power outages
besides impacts here on the ground we
also need to understand solar wind to
help us better explore deeper into space
just as ocean explorers need to
understand currents NASA needs to
understand space weather to help us send
astronauts to the moon Mars and other
distant destinations so how do we get
close enough to the Sun to actually
sample its incredibly hot atmosphere
it's complicated but as Tory McClendon
caught up with the project scientist for
this mission to help illustrate Parker's
path Tory thanks Murray Nikki thank you
for being here you're welcome so there's
so many fascinating things about this
mission one thing that I find
particularly interesting is the unusual
orbit that Parker's gonna take once it
launches can you explain that yes once
we're in space it's a very busy first
couple of weeks for us we have to get it
commissioned and all ready to go because
just six weeks after launch we encounter
the planet Venus for the first time we
use Venus to give us a little gravity
assist basically it's like a little
handbrake turn and it focuses our orbit
in towards the Sun because we don't want
to be dragged around in any way or
influenced by the Earth's orbit and so
during our 24 orbits of our seven year
mission we actually will do these flybys
of Venus another six times and each time
as you can see from this animation our
orbit is getting smaller and smaller
until those final three orbits we are at
our final closest approach speaking of
closest approach can you describe
exactly how close the parker Solar Probe
spacecraft is going to get to the Sun
yes at our closest approach we will be
three point eight three million miles
above the Sun surface and I realize that
you just thought million
doesn't sound very close but you know
the earth and the Sun are 93 million
miles apart and so if I put the earth
and the Sun in the end zones of a
football field parka Solar Probe would
tuck and run all the way to the Suns 4
yard line well in the red zone knocking
on the door for a touchdown right by
that goal line
well that sounds extremely close to me
so I'm sure that folks are now wondering
how is a spacecraft not going to burn up
at the 4 yard line
we have a wonderful heat shield that we
keep oriented between us and the Sun and
so it keeps everything in the main body
of the spacecraft nice and cool it kind
of creates a shadow and it has a white
coating on it that was specially
designed for Parker Solar Probe very
much like you prefer to be in a white
car on a hot day instead of a black car
on a hot day the heat shield is glowing
and it is reflecting a lot of the sun's
energy and so the front side of the heat
shield gets to about 2500 degrees
Fahrenheit but everything on the main
body in that shadow is it about 85
degrees Fahrenheit so much like a
pleasant Florida even that sounds so
lovely well Nikki thank you so much for
being here today we're all extremely
excited about this mission go Parker
Solar Probe and with that Mergui we'll
go back to you thanks Tori data
collected by Parker Solar Probe will
provide an unprecedented picture of the
Sun NASA edges Franklin Fitzgerald is
live on set now with senior Helio
physicist Eric Christian hi Franklin
Murray how are you great thing I'm here
as you said with Eric Christian now Eric
you have a suite of instruments when
Parker Solar Probe tell us about that
intrados instruments and what you're
trying to do so I'm deputy principal
investigator of the ISA suite which
stands for integrated scientific
investigation to the Sun we study solar
energetic particles the highest energy
particles coming off the Sun these
particles can be moving at more than
half the speed of light and they're the
ones that are most interesting from a
damage point of view from space weather
now when you talk about a damage
point-of-view are you talking about
damage to us here on earth or satellites
in like astronauts so here on earth were
both protected
by the Earth's magnetic fields and by
the atmosphere of the earth so large
particles can't really make it through
we're not in danger here but spacecraft
in orbit can be damaged by the solar
energetic particles and astronauts
especially as they get beyond the
Earth's magnetic field what we call the
magnetosphere
so as we're exploring the solar system
it's we're going back to the moon as
we're heading toward sending astronauts
towards Mars we have to understand these
solar energetic particles so that we can
predict when the astronauts are going to
get them and protect them now when you
talk about prediction are you talking
about similar to the predictions we have
for hurricanes that come toward the
United States yeah so we're studying
solar storms and in order to be able to
predict them we need to understand some
basic science about these solar storms
so that we can make the models that do
the prediction just as meteorologists
use atmospheric models that are very
complicated in order to be able to
predict the track and strength of
hurricanes
we're far behind the terrestrial weather
but we're trying to get to the point
where we can actually predict space
weather and Parker Solar Probe is going
to be a key part of that
now this ISA suite of instruments is
actually gonna look at the origin of the
space weather around the Sun so we don't
understand how these particles get
accelerated up to half the speed of
light we see them here at Earth but the
signatures from where they're coming
from we're on the Sun when they're
exactly coming is all smeared out as
they travel 93 million miles between the
Sun and the earth by being really close
we're gonna be able to identify what
parts of the Sun these particles are
directly coming from and exactly when
they are so we can use images then to
look at the sunset oh that's what's
happening there and understand the very
origin of the solar jet ik particles now
Parker Solar Probe is going to be
looking at three questions total that
they're trying to find out information
about the Sun now we're your your suite
of instruments will cover one question
and when we come back in about 15 or 20
minutes we're going to talk to dr. Eric
Christian about the other two questions
that Parker Solar Probe will look at
during this mission Murray back to you
all right thanks Franklin we look
forward to that let's check in now with
Josh and Mick in the mission director
Center for an update and a closer look
at the Delta for heavy one of the
world's most powerful rockets guys Thank
You Murray I'm Josh and I'm joined by
Mick woman from the NASA's launch
services program and Mick tonight's
launch is on the delta 4 heavy with the
additional third stage at it onto it can
you tell me a little bit about the Delta
for y absolutely Josh the you know the
due to the extremely high energy
required for this mission the delta 4
heavy launch vehicle was chosen to put
parker Solar Probe into its trajectory
the launch vehicle is unique in that it
has three first stages core common core
boosters are made up of hydrogen fuel
loads each of them has an RS 68a engine
which provides that initial thrust to
get out of Earth's atmosphere a Delta
cryogenic second stage with an RL 10 B
engine is used to achieve the
intermediate escape orbit once it's in
space and a unique feature of the delta
4 heavy that you mentioned is the solid
fuel third stage provided by Northrop
Grumman innovation systems called the
star 48 bv it's a vector Bowl third
stage and that will provide the final
push for Parker Solar Probe on its
trajectory towards the Sun you know of
course during ascent we want to protect
Parker Solar Probe so it's inside of a
63 foot by sector composite fairing that
you see on top of the Delta 4 there and
all of these key features play an
important role in getting Parker Solar
Probe on its way to the Sun so it takes
a lot of people to get a rocket like
this off members of NASA United Launch
Alliance airforce Northrop Grumman and
more can you can you tell me a little
about that the partnership that it takes
to get this yeah it's done absolutely it
is a team effort all the way around to
get a mission this far and prepared for
launch mission teams working around the
country built tested and prepared the
rocket the spacecraft ahead of launch
this morning this included teams from
United Launch Alliance in Denver
Colorado and in their production
facility at Decatur Alabama NASA's
Goddard Space Flight Center in Greenbelt
Maryland John Hopkins Applied Physics
lab in Laurel Maryland and the team
right here in Florida we had a
spacecraft team processing Parker Solar
Probe over an Astra Tech in Titusville
Florida and of course those folks here
the launch teams at
Canaveral Air Force Station in the
mission directors Center and the Delta
Operations Center and that's a live shot
there inside hangar AE
and now inside the Doppler Delta
Operations Center where NASA launch
manager Omar Baez and the ula launch
director Luo man Jerry are working with
teams to launch the delta 4 heavy that
you see on your screen there which a
launch time is now targeted for 353 a.m.
so Mick and I will continue to monitor
the countdown here in the mission
directors Center and we'll go back to
Murray for more about the NASA's Parker
Solar Probe Murray all right thanks guys
Tory is standing by live now at one of
our launch viewing areas with one of
NASA's senior leaders dr. Thomas is our
Buchan Tory thanks Murray
dr. sue Buchan you lead NASA's science
Mission Directorate tell us about the
significance of this mission and what it
means and why we need to study the Sun
up close this is one of our
strategically important missions and the
core mission in the heliophysics program
which is one of the four disciplines
where we're studying it's so important
because of two reasons first of all it's
a basic astrophysics question is how
stars he their atmospheres their corona
and especially our star the most
important star in the whole universe
which is ours how it does that just by
itself that's a really worthwhile
question and it's worth your studying
but it's also important because of space
sweater namely that the star that corona
is immersing us here at Earth and our
astronauts and is part of the hazards of
space and we want to learn how to
predict that because it affects our
lives and our technological
infrastructure both in space and on the
ground absolutely so I understand that
this is the very first mission in which
NASA named a spacecraft after a living
person
dr. Eugene Parker and I also understand
that you were the one who had the
opportunity to make that phone call so
tell us what that means to you and why
it was so important to name this mission
after him
so first of all there's only one name
that fits on that mission it's the name
of the pioneer that started it all and
frankly I figured out with my team that
our 35 missions in our entire portfolio
that studied the kind of things that Jim
Parker predicted or studied through
scientific life done so it's just
incredible here all of our science
community and it was really exciting you
know I knew again from being a young
scientist and getting to know him
admiring him and it was really cool to
call him up and kind of surprise him a
little bit I remember it's like you know
first you know it's like you know I
explained who I am is like yeah I met
you it's like okay like would you be
okay if we named a mission after you is
like I guess so
first person will ever have been asked
that kind of question so it's just
really cool what an incredible
opportunity
so dr. Parker is going to be here with
us today I mean what is it what are you
thinking that about the fact that you
are about to watch this launch right
alongside him I think it's just
absolutely incredible for me also it's
incredible for him and his family I'm so
glad his family is here too but it's
incredible for me just because it's a
touching moment right it's kind of one
of those in a life is all about these
big arcs and you know sometimes you just
see them like however a lot of time
things come together and create these
amazing stories kind of these leaves
going forward I'm just so glad to be
here with him well thank you for joining
us and Marie with that we'll go back to
you
alright thanks Tori discovering why the
sun's outer atmosphere is so much hotter
than its surface is a mystery that dates
back almost 150 years and it remains one
of the greatest unanswered questions in
astrophysics here's a look at how far
the scientific community has come the
Sun's core is the hottest part of the
Sun but our stars temperature doesn't
behave as you might expect the core is
roughly 27 million degrees Fahrenheit
and 10 times more dense than gold
as you move outward the layers of the
Sun become cooler and
Stan's something unusual however occurs
when you reach the outermost layer while
the surface is around 10,000 degrees
Fahrenheit the corona the sun's outer
atmosphere is several hundred times
hotter that's the opposite of what
happens with a fire when it gets cooler
the farther away you get scientists call
this the coronal heating problem and
evidence for this was first uncovered
during an eclipse in 1800s the corona is
usually hard to see it's too dim to be
seen next to the sun's bright body it
can be seen with the naked eye when the
moon blocks the Sun during a total solar
eclipse to understand how this mystery
was discovered it helps to know how
scientists started studying the chemical
properties of materials on earth in the
early 1800s
instruments named spectroscopes were
invented to identify materials that
admit light when heated light enters the
spectroscope and is filtered through a
tiny hole to isolate a single area it
then bounces off a special grating that
disperses light into its different
wavelengths while sunlight contains
every wavelength scientists discovered
that every chemical element and compound
contains a unique pattern of wavelengths
that allows scientists to determine the
composition of light sources it wasn't
long before astronomers started
extracting information from the light of
distant stellar objects in 1869 two
scientists
independently decided to point a
spectroscope toward the corona during a
total solar eclipse as the sun's light
disappeared
the pattern of wavelengths changed they
saw something they had never seen before
a bright green line that did not relate
to any element found on earth for short
while scientists named it caronian it
wasn't until 70 years later that a
Swedish scientist discovered that these
lines with a result of elements such as
iron being stripped of its electrons
every element has a specific number of
electrons surrounding the nucleus as
each electron is removed more energy is
needed to remove the next one
the green line shows that iron has been
stripped of 13 of its 26 electrons
indicating that the corona needed to be
millions of degrees
counter-intuitively far hotter than the
Sun surface
scientists have since proposed a variety
of theories for what mechanisms could be
adding the extra heat into the
atmosphere one theory suggests that
small waves in the sun's surface pushes
particles and heat into the atmosphere a
bit like how ocean waves pushed surfers
another theory suggests more bomb-like
explosions from the realignment of the
sun's magnetic field create heat many
scientists think it may be a mix of both
we've studied the corona from earth
during many eclipses but to solve our
stars biggest mystery we have to make
direct observations from the region
itself
[Music]
we've had some stormy weather these last
few days here at the Cape but it's been
pretty clear overnight so far let's
check in with Josh and Mick in the
mission director Center for weather
update guys Thank You Murray we are just
a few moments out from receiving a
weather briefing from the 45th Space
Wing don't launch weather office tonight
will give us our final weather briefing
for the launch countdown which launch
teams need to know but when we're also a
little bit out from entering a hold and
it can be a little bit the hold yeah the
t-minus for or hold that's coming up is
the last opportunity for the team to
take a look at the vehicle all aspects
of their sensors and data everything
that's going on with the Delta 4 launch
vehicle this evening to make sure
they're ready to enter the count and
they've finished up their cryogenic
loading or should say work on working on
finishing that up going into topping and
maintaining of the first and second
stage getting ready to cycle vent vows
and test out those areas of the first
and second stage
so this hold will give them the chance
to just kind of do one last look of the
vehicle and verify that everything is
ready and and proceeding forward for a
launch that early this morning so while
we wait for the whole which will bring
to you live can you tell us a little bit
about the US Air Force and other things
they do so not only do they look at
weather they also look at what's called
colas or collision avoidance and we
heard earlier in the countdown that
there are no colas for the T zero time
or what the launch window but can you
tell us why we look at that about the
cola process yeah absolutely the the
weather the launch window tonight we've
mentioned is 65 minutes we've used up
some of that already so we have 45
minutes left in the window and the US
Air Force performs a cola or collision
avoidance analysis one of the
considerations they have to do in
analyzing is for objects in space for
example there might be other satellites
that are around Earth that could be in
the flight path of the delta 4 heavy
tonight once we launch so as we look at
this analysis as you said there are no
cutouts or no colas for this evening in
the launch window for the teams that
they have to be aware of so they'll
continue to process forward with this 45
minute window
one of the interesting things about it
is they actually start the coal
analysis several days before launch and
then provide the last report up to the
launch managers on launch day and get
ready to help determine the t0 for
today's launch and it sounds like we're
just about to tie into this weather
briefing this RC on weather conference
net eight and a cait ready to proceed LD
LD NLM NLM Ald AFL DS and we'll proceed
yellow there's no clouds effect area and
not expecting to have anything
significant affect our area in the next
30 minutes looking at our constraints
were going all constraints and not a
concern for any space weather as well
currently now we have just a 5% chance
of violating launch constraints this
concludes the weather briefing unless
for any questions indicate questions are
acknowledged LD LD NLM NLM no questions
Ald a if LD this is weatherbury Thank
You al and that was the weather briefing
that you just heard short and sweet
which means we have good weather for the
night as you can see on your screen the
delta 4 heavy there no clouds that were
concerned with today earlier in the
count we were a little bit worse off but
we've gotten better so no claps to worry
about or go on all constraints that
probability of violation which is the
POV number do you see there is 5 percent
mean that were 95 percent go
the winds are about 5 knots out of the
West and temperatures sitting at about
78 79 degrees so no concerns for us
tonight which is a really good thing and
so that's a Delta 4 that you see on your
screen there with the additional third
stage and we're at now at t-minus eight
minutes 20 seconds and counting and for
that we'll go back to Murray Lewis for
more information all right thanks Josh
Parker Solar Probe will set off to soak
up the Sun in about 28 minutes but it's
already had quite the journey here's a
look at the months of work that led to
this moment
[Music]
[Music]
for those of you just joining us welcome
to our live coverage of the Parker Solar
Probe mission to kiss the Sun and unlock
its mysteries
Parker Solar Probe is targeted to launch
at 3:53 this morning Eastern Time from
launch complex 37 at Cape Canaveral Air
Force Station in Florida the launch
window will be open for 65 minutes
Parker will take off on a United Launch
Alliance Delta 4 heavy rocket speeding
up to four hundred thirty thousand miles
per hour in orbit that's fast enough to
get from Philadelphia to Washington DC
in one second it will travel seven times
closer to the Sun than any spacecraft
before Parker will help us understand
how the Sun affects weather in space and
why is that important well first a
little background
Parker Solar Probe is named after dr.
Eugene Parker a physicist who figured
out 60 years ago that our star actually
has its own wind and storms and they
could spread far into space this space
weather can disrupt communication
signals from our satellites and even
cause power outages
besides impacts here on the ground we
also need to understand solar wind to
help us explore deeper into space just
as ocean explorers need to understand
currents NASA needs to understand space
weather to help us send astronauts to
the moon Mars and other distant
destinations
to help us understand more about this
space weather let's go over to Tori with
a live guest to help explain Tori thanks
Marie
Nikki let's talk space weather help us
and help us understand
dr. Parker's theory of the solar wind so
a lot of people get very excited about
big space weather events when we have
coronal mass ejections and flares and
storms but what a lot of people don't
realize is that the Sun is continually
throwing off this solar wind it is
continually expanding and bathing all of
the planets so even if it isn't a really
big storm we can still see the impact of
space weather here on earth because the
solar wind is continually buffeting our
planet when we see the very big events
however that lets a lot of energy into
the Earth's magnetosphere and down into
our atmosphere causing it to glow we
think of that as the very beautiful
northern and southern lights that's a
current system in the sky and that can
cause problems for Peregrine's here on
earth problems for spacecraft out in in
orbit problems for astronauts problems
the GPS accuracy lots and lots of
impacts of space weather all driven by
the solar wind as predicted by Jean
Parker so there's a lot of great reasons
we should be going on this mission and
exploring the Sun yes and what about
this has been 60 years in the making
right so how has this mission involved
since then so it's kind of an
interesting thing because we've had to
wait for our technology to really catch
up with what we want to do and yet it's
because we have so much technology here
on earth now that we rely on every day
we're now even more susceptible to the
Sun than we were 60 years ago if you
think 60 years ago if you wanted to make
a phone call you've had a rotary dial
phone there was attached to a wall and
now you hold it in the palm of your hand
with more technology than you can even
believe and so we've needed that leap in
technology to be able to enable us to do
this incredible mission that is
definitely incredible and what about you
personally you've been you've been on
this mission for eight years now yes
eight years and so it's a it's it's a
long it's been a long road but it seems
like it's gone by like that
it's just wonderful to work with this
team and it's incredible to be standing
here today looking at that delta 4 heavy
over there and waiting for it to take
two guys I will you be watching the
launch with dr. Parker himself I will be
I'm privileged I was standing right
behind him or as close to him as I can
be and I can't wait to see the look on
his face when that delta 4 heavy clears
the pad wonderful well I have to say one
of the things I've admired most about
throughout this mission has been your
incredible wardrobe Oh today's rocket
yes yes well we're definitely looking
forward to this incredible launch and
with that Marie we'll go back to you
alright thanks Tori and Nikki let's go
back to Franklin with more from Helio
physicist Eric Christian Franklin Thank
You Marie
Eric during our first segment we talked
about the first question that Parker
Solar Probe is going to answer but there
were actually two more tell us about
them so one of the questions you saw a
nice presentation from NASA on and
that's the coronal heating problem why
is the corona of so much hotter than the
surface of the Sun really strange
Parker Solar Probe is going to be in the
region where the corona is still being
heated and so we can exactly see exactly
where that heat is coming from the other
question is how is the solar wind this
stream of particles of blows out from
the Sun in all directions how is that
accelerating up to a million miles an
hour we don't know and from Earth the
entire signature of the origin gets
smeared out 93 million miles as it
travels from the Sun to the earth we
need to be close to the Sun in order to
answer these basic questions yeah we
were talking about the the smearing that
you were talking about just now earlier
today when we're doing a rollback
segments and you said that the solar
winds from the Sun can stretch as far as
Pluto they go out way beyond Pluto
actually the Sun has blown a bubble in
interstellar space that we call the
heliosphere
it's what helium physicists consider to
be the solar system goes out beyond the
orbit of Pluto and we now have a
spacecraft Voyager 1 that for the first
time has left
that bubble everything inside that
bubble is solar wind particles solar
wind magnetic field outside is
interstellar space the space in between
the stars so we have an interstellar
probe now in Voyager one hopefully
Voyager 2 will be joining it soon now
when we talk about solar solar weather
solar storms you mentioned to me a story
about dr. Parker and how he looked at a
comet and how solar weather affected the
comet tell that tell us about that so
one of the interesting thing about
comets is the tails don't lead or follow
the comet's movement this comet tails
always point away from the Sun in the
only way that can happen if something is
blowing off the Sun faster than the
comet is moving and it was that clue
that led Jean Parker to writing down the
theory of the solar wind for the first
time now when we talk about theories do
you have any that you are actually
looking at when it comes to what Parker
Solar Probe is actually going to find
when it flies through the corner of the
Sun so there are several competing
theories for all the questions that
we're talking about all three I'll bet
they're all wrong every time we've
gotten someplace new in the solar system
we've been surprised I fully expect to
be surprised by this mission
it's got great instruments we're going
to some place so that no one's ever been
to before we're going to learn something
new and that's the fun part of science
well that's great to hear and we
definitely look forward to getting the
data from the Parker Solar Probe dr.
Christian thanks for being with us today
Maria back to you Thank You Franklin
Parker Solar Probe will use its heat
shield to protect itself against the Sun
the shield is so robust watches
engineers from Johns Hopkins Applied
Physics lab use a blowtorch to
demonstrate how it works
[Music]
here we have a piece of the heat shield
for Parker Solar Probe which is a
sandwich panel made of carbon that's
like the graphite epoxy you might find
in your golf clubs your tennis racquets
some carbon foam and then another piece
of carbon carbon on the back it's very
lightweight as you can see and here I've
got a blowtorch and I'm gonna use it to
get the front surface of this glowing
hot and then we'll have a nice
demonstrator come in and touch the back
like this and so let's get this started
you can start seeing it glowing red the
real heat shield gets up to about 2500
degrees Fahrenheit which we're not going
to do today but we are going to get it
to a couple hundred degrees Fahrenheit
so it's going pretty good now throw it
as whether you touch the back surface of
that what does it feel like
nice and cool he says
which is just how we like it keeping the
spacecraft we are now just minutes from
liftoff let's go over to the mission
director center for a live update from
United Launch Alliance and then Josh
will take us through the count Josh
thank you very much I'm now joined by
Elissa Macbeth from United Launch
Alliance welcome to the program Elissa
thank you for having me it's great to be
here and Elissa can you tell me a little
bit about ula and what has been like to
work on this park or Solar Probe mission
yeah
so it's so exciting to always get to
work on an interplanetary mission it's a
great opportunity for you LA to launch a
rocket that will put the satellite in
orbit to Venus and eventually to the Sun
that's very exciting that we get to play
a part in exploring the solar system and
so I understand that you also brought a
video with you that shows a little bit
about the Delta for after that t0 moment
where it takes off do do the flight and
show us the video sure sure 3 Delta 4
rs-68 a main engines ignite and generate
more than 2.1 million pounds of thrust
to lift the rocket away from the pad the
Delta 4 reaches Mach 1 the speed of
sound at one minute 18 seconds at 3
minutes 56 seconds the port and
starboard booster engines shut down two
seconds later the boosters are jettison
at five minutes 36 seconds propellant
levels deplete the main engine shuts
down seven seconds later the delta force
separation system activates to release
the first stage
at five minutes 55 seconds the first
Delta cryogenic second stage or DCSS
main engine burn begins at approximately
six minutes five seconds the payload
fairing is jettisoned at ten minutes 37
seconds cut off of the DCSS engine or
Miko one occurs at 22 minutes 25 seconds
the DCSS main engine has be started for
the second burn approximately 14 minutes
later second cut off of the DCSS main
engine occurs following a 30-second
coast phase the third stage is separated
20 seconds later the third stage is
ignited approximately one minute 29
seconds later burnout of the third stage
solid rocket motor occurs at 43 minutes
10 seconds the third stage releases
NASA's Parker's Solar Probe spacecraft
on its journey to the Sun
so it looks like it gets pretty exciting
at t0 for the delta 4 heavy with the
additional third stage so you're often
on constant for United Launch Alliance
missions and can you characterize what
it's like to sit on console during a
mission yes definitely so overall it's
very exciting to be on console but at
this point we have prepared and planned
and spent so much time - up until this
point that we're just ready to go at
this point so what else is cool about
United Launch Alliance is that we have a
team of people at the launch site as
well as in Denver our headquarters that
are supporting on consoles so these are
the systems engineers who are experts in
launching rockets and they have gotten
to this point where they are they know
everything to the minut detail of what's
going on and like I said we're just
ready to go and we're excited to be a
part of it and so can you tell me what's
happened up to this point that countdown
and what we can expect before launch
yeah so we're about to enter into hold
in a couple minutes here so at this
point the rocket is fully fueled there
are a team of engineers who have
performed some testing final testing on
the avionics systems and at this point
we are not working anything but getting
ready for that final poll before we head
into the terminal count
so United Launch Alliance has facilities
all over the US can you talk more about
about ula as a whole and what they put
forward to design build and launch this
parker Solar Probe mission and how do
the team's company-wide work yeah
definitely so it takes a large group of
people exemplary people to get where we
are at this point so we have design
engineers who brilliantly produce and
develop a rocket and then the production
sites in Alabama in Texas provide a
perfect product to the launch site where
we put it all together and and do the
final installations and hook up
to prepare for launch so yeah we
teamwork is a standard at ula there's no
doubt about it that we hold that to a
high high degree and we wouldn't be we
wouldn't be United Launch Alliance
without that team so yeah all the sites
are working together and to get us to
this point and for those of you that are
just joining us I'm sitting here with
Elissa Macbeth of United Launch Alliance
and we're inside of the t-minus four
minute hold this is a 20 minute hold so
on our launch clock we're about 11
minutes 40 seconds and counting on your
screen you're looking at a live shot of
the Delta 4 at Space Launch Complex 37
which is the East Coast home for the
delta 4 heavy rocket ELISA can you
explain to me why this mission is so
significant to United Launch Alliance
yeah so this is actually our sixth
launch of this year it's a hundred and
twenty ninth successful launch as ula
since we formed in 2006 as you said
there are three stages with this with
this specific payload and the energy
required is something that only our
vehicle can do it's the only rocket out
there that can do what Solar Parker
Solar Probe needs it to do so it's
definitely significant in terms of
performance of our rocket we get to kind
of show off here a little bit and show
the world what you la can do and again
on your screen another shot of the
United Launch Alliance Delta 4 be rocked
Space Launch Complex 37 behind it you
see the mobile service tower which is
used to it provides an access point for
the rocket can you tell us a little bit
more about what the mobile service tower
does when it's around the rocket yeah so
the mobile service tower provides
360-degree access so any part of the
rocket that you would need to do get to
in order to install box that avionics
pocket boxes or get to the engines or
install ordnance these that mobile
service tower provides that access to do
that and then at t0 that access goes
away so you can see you have the mobile
service tower well the is
called the fixed umbilical tower there
and those arms will swing away and there
as the rocket lifts off so word an L -
ten minutes and Counting on the L clock
that T clock is still stopped at the
team - four-minute mark before we launch
NASA's Parker Solar Probe yes Allah will
determine the structure and dynamics of
the sun's coronal magnetic field it'll
understand how the solar corona and wind
are heated and accelerated and determine
what mechanism accelerate and transport
energetic particles that was United
Launch Alliance indicating how to
indicate a hold of the count although
we're still marching toward a liftoff at
3:53 a.m. Eastern Time we are inside of
a team - for a minute hold ready to
proceed
LM verify red eye monitor and event
table are in the correct configuration /
terminal count verified
you're still looking at a live shot
there the base of the Delta for rocket
and Alisa can you tell me a little bit
more about the Delta four yeah
so the Delta four stands at
approximately two hundred and thirty
three feet tall with a 5 meter payload
fairing its first launch was December
21st in 2004 and has had successful
launches since then it is fully capable
of launching up to 14,000 pounds of
payload and it has a unique ability with
its second stage to deliver a payload
anywhere it needs to go in the solar
system including the Sun and we're
sitting at about a minute out from one
of our poles can you tell us a little
bit about what's coming up at the L
minus seven mark yeah L minus seven like
I said we're we're in a point where
we've reached all of our milestones
throughout the countdown and we're
getting ready to pull which is basically
a go from each of our systems engineers
to say that their systems are ready for
launch so the launch conductor will go
through the list of engineers they all
will respond with a go and that is an
indication that the lunch is ready
and the Delta heavies ready to fly so
we're about 30 seconds from the pole
that Alisa Macbeth of United Launch
Alliance was just talking about on your
screen you see the delta 4 heavy rocket
poised for liftoff at 353 a.m. 15
seconds before the the pole
status check to proceed with terminal
count first ace isn't propulsion go
hydraulics go locks o LH to go second
stage systems locks go H to go third
stage systems third stage vehicle
manager go electrical systems
airborne go ground tow facility are FFTs
well flight control go calm go gcq go
operations support no go pending the
resolution of patisserie normally just
briefed on six Roger
pneumatics go umbilicals go has gas go
ACS go redline monitor go quality go ops
safety manager go your lay safety else
go vehicle system engineer no go via me
status Roger not my chief no go via me
status dr. rice corn air clear to
proceed
Roger ldl-c LD on one yeah we have a
no-go conditions going to not ready with
your direction
Roger LC switch not ready AC please
inform me of the not ready condition we
will get your report as soon as possible
project and as you just heard that was
the poll done at the L minus seven mark
and as you heard on the countdown that
there right now in a no-go status will
stand by for more information
they all personnel on that one I'll
cooperate maintain a system readiness
well the anomaly team to investigate the
condition and be ready for a new t0
coordination
if you're just joining us you see that
the clocks are at L minus four minutes t
minus four minutes during the terminal
count readiness poll that would allow us
to exit the t minus four minute hold we
had a condition but the teams are
looking into as we speak and so we'll
look to establish a new t0 at a time
coming up
Mik and I will continue to monitor the
situation here from the from the mission
directors Center and we'll bring you
more as we know
we're here in their mission director
center monitoring as launch teams
continue to work toward a liftoff time
make can you tell me what the launch
teams are working on
yeah the teams right now are you know in
the t-minus four holding
you heard the pole for the no-go
situation that they're doing and so
they're taking it this chance while the
assessment is being done to evaluate
what's going on the other parts of the
team are taking a look at the rocket and
just verifying that all other aspects of
the vehicle are still within
specifications and ready to proceed
forward with a t0 tonight so as the EGS
ii team takes a look at what's going on
they'll get back to the launch director
and launch conductor to let them know
their resolution and we'll look forward
for a new t0 as we continue to hold here
at t minus four using up some of the
window that's still available right now
we have 39 minutes left in the launch
availability window for this evening's
launch so you're looking at a live shot
at the delta 4 heavy with the additional
third stage on your screen there make
and I will continue to monitor the count
and we'll bring you updates as we know
it
you
you're looking at a live shot of the
delta 4 heavy rocket at Space Launch
Complex 37 on Cape Canaveral Air Force
Station on the bottom of the right of
your screen you see the t clock which is
stopped at the t-minus four minute mark
make can you tell us a little bit about
the clocks
yeah the T clock and is used by the team
to continue working through the launch
procedure we also have an L clock which
has the built-in hold times of course
we're at the t minus four and holding
point right now so there's no more hold
time remaining so we're actually in this
hold pattern using ups of our available
launch window this evening we had 45
minutes left over in our launch window
we're down to 35 minutes in that launch
available window right now as teams
continue to work through the issues that
they've identified during the last poll
- before moving into terminal count you
know it's been a very busy morning for
us here starting with tower roll all the
way through fueling there have been a
lot of things the team has been working
and they continue to work diligently
through this issue as they want to
assess and make sure everything is in
perfect order before moving into the
terminal count for a on time liftoff
later this morning so while the t clock
holds at the t minus 4 mark we'll
continue to monitor the launch teams and
we'll bring you more updates
from the launch control we're at the
t-minus four minute mark in holding on
your screen you see the Delta four there
the delta 4 heavy with the additional
third stage teams are continuing to work
although the t clock is stopped and
we'll bring you more information as we
know it for the launch of nasa's parker
solar probe the parker solar probes
observations from directly inside the
corona will help scientists understand
why the sun's atmosphere is some 1,000
times hotter than its surface
the mission will provide unprecedented
ly close observations of the solar wind
the constant outflow of solar material
hurled from the Sun at a million miles
per hour
NASA's Parker Solar Probe will also
study how solar eruptions accelerate
particles to such energies that they can
pose a hazardous condition for
astronauts and technology in space
understanding more about the fundamental
processes near the Sun will provide key
information to better understand their
effects on the space environment near
Earth such as base weather damage to
orbits of satellites
shorten their lifetimes or interfere
with onboard electronics the more we
learn about what causes base weather and
how to predict it the better we can
protect the satellites we depend on
understanding more about space weather
also helps protect astronauts from
dangerous radiation exposure during
potential human spaceflight missions
exploring the Moon and Mars the Sun is
the only star that can be studied up
close observing the star we live near
sheds light on stars throughout the
universe
Parker Solar Probe is a newest addition
to NASA's heliophysics fleet missions
that study the vast interconnected
system from the Sun to the space
surrounding earth and other planets to
the farthest limits of the sun's
constantly flowing streams of solar wind
Parker Solar Probe provides key
information about how the Sun drives
this dynamic and complex system
lc1 is a cm rate our brief the the
immediate disable hit Roger LD that one
LD NLM net one NLM proceed acing okay
this occurred about a minute after the
expected response from the ground PC he
assumed stream this is from the vehicle
team has evaluated the data we recognize
it was from the people the streams are
good and we are in a good position to
proceed that the risk level is the same
as what we had discussed previously and
and voted to proceed so the anomaly team
is recommending we try again
LC concurs LD LD concurs and LM LM
concurs
and you're looking at a live shot of the
delta 4 heavy at Space Launch Complex 37
if you're just joining us we are at t
minus 4 and holding we started tonight
with a sixty five minute window we now
are down to 23 minutes but can make can
you tell us a little bit what we just
heard on countdown 1 yeah absolutely the
team evaluated the vehicle from the
no-go situation they had in the t-minus
four pole a little earlier what they
were working on was the ground data
stream that comes from the launch
vehicle back to the computers in a
control center and the team looked at
that data hit that they had gotten and
have determined that they completely
understand it and the data stream has
returned race one and comfort good and
they are ready to proceed forward as
they reported to the launch conductor
Roger 0 8 to 8 : 4 0 Zillah RC LC RC on
one please coordinated new T 0 0 8 to 8
Roger work ALC please set the clock for
zero wait wait Roger OBM helsing at one
go LC new target t zero zero eight two
eight zero zero zero
copy target zero eight two eight zero
zero Zulu we'll proceed into checklist a
Roger LC clock has been set for a new
teaser of Oh a 28 or approximately l6
Roger
and from Delta launch control I'm Josh
and I'm joined with Mick Wolfman from
NASA's launch service program and and we
just heard a countdown from the launch
teams can you characterize LT yes Josh
what the team was doing is we were
talking a little earlier the team
evaluated around data stream from the
launch vehicle they've determined they
are good to proceed with launch this
evening so NASA's launch manager Omar
Baez and United Launch Alliance is
launch director Lumi and jury have
coordinated into t zero time this
morning for 428 a.m. that's
approximately sixteen minutes from now
to get parker Solar Probe on its way
towards the Sun so we're hoping for a
smooth liftoff this evening as the teams
continue to work forward and through the
count procedure and get ready to pick up
the count coming out of the t-minus four
hold and so we'll pick up that count in
just over ten minutes I believe that is
correct
Elle minutes 14 minutes
he'll see okay go BM third-stage recycle
checklist pay is complete we're on
external power Roger
from Delta launch control you're looking
at a live view of the delta 4 heavy
rocket with the additional third stage
at Space Launch Complex 37 on Cape
Canaveral Air Force Station I'm Josh and
I'm joined by mickey wolfmann of NASA's
launch services program we've
coordinated a new t0 for 428 a.m. which
will leave about 10 minutes left in our
window and Mickey can you tell me now
that we've reset the clock to about L
minus 12 minutes what we can expect yeah
as we move forward from here the launch
teams will continue to work through
their procedure stepping through all
aspects of the Delta 4 launch vehicle
and as they get ready to enter into the
terminal count what we will see is the
launch teams prepping the FDS system and
getting it armed and ready to go we'll
see the third stage enter onto internal
power as they perform their testing and
get ready for launch and then the delta
launch vehicle second stage and first
stage will also enter onto internal
power and ready for those final few
minutes prior to liftoff this morning
and then about just prior to liftoff
will have the rs-68 engines being purged
with a hydrogen purge that's going
through there and that will fill up
around the engines and create some
pockets around the Delta for heavy
launch vehicle once the rs-68 engine
ignites it'll actually look like the
delta 4 heavy is engulfed in in flames a
little bit but that's actually normal
for a delta 4 heavy launch vehicle
because of that hydrogen purge that
started prior to launch and that all
catches in the ignition of the RF 68 so
the team will be very busy in those last
four minutes prepping for the count and
moving forward towards a liftoff at 428
this morning and can you tell us a
little bit more about the delta 4 heavy
that we're looking at on our screen yeah
absolutely as we talked a little earlier
this but this particular delta 4 heavy
for parker Solar Probe has three common
booster cores each with an rs-68 engine
which is a hydrogen fueled engine that
provides the thrust to get out of
Earth's atmosphere sitting on top of the
center core is a Delta kraj and except
second stage
just powered by an RL 10 B engine which
will provide that intermediate escape
velocity for the Parker Solar Probe
mission once it's in space moving up the
stack you have the five meter fairing
which is encompassing Parker Solar Probe
and the mission unique third stage that
was provided by Northrop Grumman
innovation systems a star 48 B V Lowden
it's a vector motor once on this page
once in space star 48 and provide that
last little push for Parker's Solar
Probe to eat it into its trajectory
heading towards the Sun another unique
thing and we keep talking about this
being a historic mission today Josh it
is a very historic mission of getting
Parker's Solar Probe onto the Sun as
this has been thought about for the last
60 years to get out and study the Sun
but for some of our viewing audience
Launch Complex 37 is also a historic
launch pad back in 1960s it was used as
part of the Apollo program launching
Saturn ones and Saturn one B's it was
also the place where we launched the
first unmanned lunar module from and
then ula acquired launch complex 37 in
2001 and began their program of Delta
for launches from here so it's a
historic launch all the way around for a
United Launch Alliance and NASA this
evening and so for tonight it'll launch
NASA's Parker Solar Probe which will
make repeated journeys into the Sun's
corona and trace the flow of energy to
answer fundamental questions such as why
this of our atmosphere is dramatically
hotter than the Sun surface
what accelerates the solar wind that
blows outward through the solar system
and what is the source of this
high-energy solar particles Parker Solar
Probe will make 24 elliptical orbits of
the Sun and even use 7 Venus flybys to
shrink the orbit closer to the Sun
during the seven year mission the probe
will fly seven times closer to the Sun
than any spacecraft before a mere 3.9
million miles above the surface which is
about 4% of the distance from the Sun to
the earth at the closest approach Parker
Solar Probe will reach a top speed of
four hundred and thirty thousand miles
per hour or 120 miles per hour per
second making it the fastest spacecraft
in history
we're just about a minute from our
status check for continuing the count
t-minus four and holding
status check to proceed with terminal
cow first stage systems propulsion go
hydraulics go box go now H to go second
stage systems locks go H to go third
stage systems third stage vehicle
manager go back spell systems airborne
go ground go facility are FFTs yo flight
control go come commas go
jcq go operations for go pneumatics go
umbilicals go pass gas go
ACS go red light monitor go quality go
op safety manager go Haley safety
officer go vehicle system engineer go
and I my chief go rice corn a clear to
proceed
launch director you have permission to
launch
proceeding with the count and make you
establish swing on lock pins pulled
active
from Delta launch control you just heard
the terminal count readiness poll with
permission to continue the count I'm
joined by Mick Roman of NASA's launch
services program make can you get us up
to speed on where we are tonight yes for
those just tuning in we're getting ready
to come out of the t-minus four hold
with a new t0 of 428 a.m. this morning
the T clock had stopped at t-minus four
giving the team time to work through the
DGSE issue that they had identified
earlier in the count the t clock as we
like to refer is the official countdown
clock it stopped the t-minus for mark
and held there for some minutes to allow
the team to assess the health of the
Delta 4 launch vehicle as we proceed
forward with the launch tonight at 2 428
launch teams have finished topping the
vehicle fuel the first and second stage
all systems look like they are ready to
go as we just heard the poll from the
team everyone is go to pick up the
terminal count and begin transferring to
internal power and final checks heading
towards a successful liftoff at 428 this
morning
or just about 20 seconds away from
picking up the count
and we are getting ready to come out of
the hold in 3 2 1 we are t-minus four
and counting ground Pyro's enabled
we're at t-minus three minutes 35
seconds and counting
coming up at the two and a half minute
before launch the launch conductor will
ask the NASA spacecraft coordinator to
verify this is on internal power about
15 seconds later NASA launch manager
Omar Baez will give Luo man Jerry of
United Launch Alliance he's the launch
director the NASA go or no go for launch
about one minute liftoff the launch
conductor will ask the range operations
coordinator or rock you'll hear the
status for rock to report range at
t-minus zero with United Launch Alliance
Delta four heavy will lift off from
Space Launch Complex 37 the delta 4
heavy begins flowing at its planned
trajectory and just under 45 minutes
later and NASA's Parker Solar Probe will
separate from the third stage beginning
its mission to study the Sun you just
heard the call for the flight
termination system to go internal from
now we'll be listening to the launch
teams alive from the Delta Operations
Center pressure and flight level as we
enter the final minutes of the countdown
we'll listen in to the NSA verify
spacecraft on internal power will listen
to the launch team to count down into
the final minutes of their part and the
NASA's Parker Solar Probe is verified to
be on internal power after launch we'll
hear the voice of United Launch Alliance
Patrick Moore giving real live telemetry
of the Delta Force performance
two minutes two minutes about present
4000 vehicle internal hold hold hold
this is our LM have a LC not ready
all personnel because race cycle pages
operation 90 LC said G H helium
regulator and let for us Roger okay team
we held at t-minus one minute 55 seconds
from Delta launch control we are holding
it the t-minus one minute 55 second
account we have nine minutes and 15
seconds remaining in tonight's window
my control you ready to reset the clock
to you for holding flight control is
ready for that Roger ALC reset the
countdown clock t-minus four minutes and
holding
Roger ple evaluate luxury second
reported phrasing restart lock stops
record LC answer running
LC flight control s 5s and active STS in
pre-flight mode Roger
LC countdown clock has been reset to
t-minus four minutes and holding
roger osm place S or M ignitions with a
disabled position this RM is a disabled
ovm performed third stage recycle
checklist
he'll see our week on again tonight
we're past a t-minus two minutes
negative copy that
at this point that will proceed to our
power down checklist roger ldl-c net1 LD
young one
all right all day with our scrub pastel
- or excuse me our pulled past t-minus
two minutes you need to recycle back
down - four minutes window will not
support that uh second attempt it is
correct so let's set up for our recycle
Roger
alc on TC emergency panel high-speed
cameras normal normal
from Delta launch control as you just
heard on on the live countdown net we
have expired our time in our window for
tonight's nominations recycle systems
back t-minus four and holding so we get
to recycling I go for a 24-hour
turnaround time for the launch of NASA's
Parker Solar Probe Mick and I who were
monitoring the countdown in the launch
control center
it'll be operate continue to monitor and
bring you more information as we know it
ch we go H way step to 30 so step delta
draw some stable
Roger LLC peony okay any subset of alpha
pneumatic pressure stable Roger
LCE CS go so step November ECS that
point stable Roger L CFDs on step Juliet
FDS safe an external Roger LC drop one
drop one Charlie rs.60000 system stable
project LC fuel to go first up step
hotel second stage lh2 conditioning is
complete
Roger sub step Lima GC cube ready Roger
Elsie meq go sub-steps foxtrot and oscar
has gas TSM and swingarm systems ready
Roger LLC flight control go sub step
kilo flight controls ready Roger OC you
go first
maybe air boxes be a core sternum lcov
em go
third states power down checklist is
complete Roger and ok I'm here on
external power
we're completely powered down Roger LLC
lux to go take a stage l o2 conditioning
active Roger LC fuel 1 go
TBC lh2 topping and conditioning or
active Roger LCG you want go yeah this
is ready Roger
happy
from Delta launch control
we've have script for tonight's attempt
which was targeted to go at 3:53 but we
expired our time in the window make can
you can you tell us a little more yeah
absolutely Josh you know teams worked
very hard this evening diligently
getting through the launch process
looking at everything that they had to
to get into the terminal countless
evening as we picked up the count at
t-minus four and got into terminal count
the team received a gaseous helium reg
pressure alarm that kicked them out that
was what you heard the hold hold hold on
the countdown net was four the team is
evaluating that and looking at it
unfortunately we didn't have enough time
this evening to go troubleshoot that and
try again for a launch so we're going to
lean forward here and plan for a 24 hour
turnaround tomorrow for a launch time of
331 a.m. however that is contingent upon
the D tanking process this evening and
the team continuing their evaluation of
the gaseous viim helium reg alarm if
they determine or find anything that
they can't get ready for tomorrow's
launch attempt the launch management
team will get together and determine if
we can maintain that 24-hour turnaround
or if we go to a 48 hour turnaround so
that's where we are right now
unfortunately we did scrub this evening
due to this issue but the teams will
continue to work work this problem and
move forward to try to get Parker's
Solar Probe on its way to the Sun Thank
You Mick for the update and with that
update we'll now go back to Marie Louis
Marie Josh and Mick thank you so much
for keeping us updated as you just heard
today's launch attempt has been scrubbed
and this concludes our coverage of
today's Parker Solar Probe launch
attempt for updates on the next attempt
and the Parker mission visit nasa.gov
thank you for getting up so early with
us and we invite you to rejoin us when
we try again have a great day